from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between dominoes in japan and the u.s
this is food wars
[Music]
in japan domino's pizzas come in three
sizes our domino's pizza comes in four
sizes so this one is medium which is cut
into edge slices over here on this end
you got the small that's 10 inch pizza
and here's regular
which is also cut into eight slices next
up is our medium that's a 12 inch pizza
and this one is large this one is cut
into 12 slices then we move to our large
14 inches
and finally the extra large which is 16
inches
look at all that grease
[Music]
a domino's large plain pizza has a 33
centimeters diameter or an
855.3 square centimeters area and costs
2 000 yen
so breaking the down our pizza is 2.33
yen per square inch or about 2 cents
now take our large this is a 14 inch
pizza also a
35.56 centimeter pizza and it has a
surface area of 993.1
square centimeters that's 1.4 cents per
square inch or 1.62 japanese yen but
what gives you the most food for your
money
so here is a large plain slice with a
pancreas and here is another with hand
toasted grass let's weigh both right now
and see which is more so first let's
weigh pancreas
51 grams
and hand toast crust
it weighs 49 grams
and we will do the same i want to note
that right now in america you can only
get the pan dominoes and the medium size
same exact experiment only i'm doing two
medium pizzas medium pan slice medium
hand toss slice so this is the
hand
toss
slice
and it weighs
a smidge over 75. we'll go 76. a pan
that goes in there too
110 grams
making the difference
this amount
i'm not doing math
in japan we have seven different crust
options number one we have pan
and number two we have hand tossed
and number three we have ultra crispy
it's like a cracker
number four we have cheese burst where a
string cheese is placed around the edge
of a crust and sprinkled with consomme
parmesan seasoning
number five we have the cheese roll
it's got mozzarella cheese in the crust
and number six we have mili filet
or meal foy
meal
fail in japanese we say miroufi you so
this one is mirafio pizza which has two
layers of crust with camembert mixed
cheese in between meal fail
he'll feel
french people please correct my
pronunciation
number seven
the last one we have the triple mil fail
it's got three layers of crafts with
cheese in between
wow in the u.s we have only five crust
options i realize there's four pizzas in
front of me let me explain one crust
option you can get here and it's the
small only is the gluten-free crust
i don't know
how bread
is gluten-free
but we figured it out
we also have the hand tossed
which is more of a standard pillowy i
mean this right there's like standard
deltas what we think a pizza looks like
this is the pan
look how thick that is man that's like
triple the dough thickness good onion
for the pan now you can get this in the
medium only we also have a crunchy thin
crust and we have so many pizzas here to
be honest i don't know which one it is
so when it just comes up in the video
i'll show it off but imagine a crunchy
thin pizza oddly enough we also have
something called the brooklyn style
pizza this is reserved for large and
extra large pizzas only and this is a
brooklyn style right here extra large
obviously isn't crispy because it's
sagging this is really thin
here's everything you can get at the
japanese dominoes that you cannot get in
the u.s here's everything you can get at
a us dominoes you cannot get in japan
so everyone look at this this is a
limited time offer pizza
it's called the best 34.
look at this lid
it's disgusting
don't look at me don't look at me
so this one has all 34 domino's toppings
like teriyak chicken mayo spinach tomato
shrimp this is huge
it's like my baby
[Music]
the new yorker style pizza is similar to
the brooklyn xl option you can get in
america but only in japan you can get
the cuatro new yorker it's a 16 inch
pizza with each new yorker topping style
covering a quarter of the pizza
so one quarter is pepperoni and one is
cheese and one is pepperoni and sausage
and one is ham and mushroom so here we
have nippon favorite series nippon or
nihong means japan in japanese so these
pizzas feature japanese ingredients this
one charcoal grilled teriyak chicken
it's got teriyaki chicken
teriyak sauce spinach
mayonnaise and corn next we have
hokkaido three cheeses so hokkaido is
the northern ireland prefecture in japan
and
it's famous for its cheese it's got
hokkaido gouda cheese hokkaido cheddar
cheese and hokkaido camembert and
celeste asparagus we have spicy mayo and
mochi it's got mochi rice cake and corn
pork sausage and sliced asparagus and
korean seaweed flakes and last one we've
got charcoal grilled beef and spinach
and mushrooms
um
this beef is so tender
and it's got so much like charcoal
flavor
which makes this amazing i love this
so many exclusive pizzas here at the us
dominoes i don't know where to begin so
i'll just start with this one that i'm
holding this is the cali chicken bacon
ranch i don't know what makes it
california in e or cali
but it definitely has chicken and bacon
and ranch and it's big
thank you very much all right
chicken taco pizza
oh yeah
got taco spices to it good job on this
one next one the cheeseburger pizza um
yeah oh my god
i'm gonna say something crazy this
tastes exactly like a mcdonald's
cheeseburger even has like the oniony
and the ketchupy taste
wow
that is a surprise
i thought this one's gonna be bad it's
actually pretty good the extravaganza
it says pepperoni sausage
ham
mushrooms
black olives green peppers this is the
meatzza which i'm assuming is just
a lot of meat i'm seeing sausage i'm
seeing pepperoni and maybe hamburger
yeah i'll put this in the good pile with
this one philly cheese stick oh no
in some weird way i'm blaming you for
this
since you handed this to me this is your
fault
this is a nightmare
meat somewhere on here
i'm also seeing green peppers
oh look it's like it's like
look at that it's like stuck to the box
no
buffalo chicken okay okay here's more my
speed chicken no not tomato sauce like a
white sauce good call
this isn't buffalo enough the capital of
the great state of new york needs to be
better represented in this pizza the
capital of new york is buffalo correct
no
we got the memphis bbq chicken love
memphis love barbecue love chicken
yeah
the key thing here is the barbecue sauce
i don't know what is in it but man
that's really good
memphis
capital the great state of tennessee
everyone
here is the ultra cheese new yorker
it's got one kilogram of cheese or 2.2
pounds omg
look how thick this cheese is
it weighs 180 grams
180 times eight equals
1440 grams in total so here are other
japanese specialty pizzas so here we
have cuatro meat max
says charcoal grilled teriyak chicken
and charcoal grilled beef and giga meat
and dorial galbi it's like korean style
like beef pizza and next we have seafood
special
this part and this part is shrimp
mayonnaise
so this part it's got shrimp octopus
mussels little neck clumps micro clumps
green peppers and cherry tomatoes next
we've got garlic master
looks so spicy garlic and pork sausage
and pancetta and this part it's got
jalapeno obviously it's picante
pepperoni
and italian sausage and onions and look
at this huge thing
mayo jaga
means potato in japanese
it's got potato and pork sausage and a
lot of mayo our us dominoes have
sandwiches and pasta i was not a fan of
the philly cheesesteak pizza but let's
see what the philly cheesesteak tastes
like in
its native form of sandwich
better than the pizza also the us
domino's you can get a buffalo chicken
sandwich a chicken habanero sandwich the
mediterranean veggie no thanks a chicken
bacon ranch an italian sandwich and of
course the chicken parm sandwich our
domino's has four pastas to choose from
i only got two the chicken alfredo and
the italian sausage marinara you can
also get a chicken carbonara and a pasta
primavera
i've just been informed i have to eat
this
strong flavor on this i would skip the
pasta
at domino's personally
but this thing is like baked i don't see
how big this is like come on like chef
ramsay here just got oh come on
oh it's just baked on here in the u.s we
have a few chicken options you can't get
in japan yes japan has wings but they
don't have these flavors visually i can
see why
first flavor we got here
is the garlic parmesan
hey domino's
what are you doing next one we got i'm
assuming this is the
honey barbecue but these drizzles what
are you guys doing drizzling man just
toss it
toss it in the sauce nobody wants a
drizzle
oh wait a second
this is a sweet mango habanero i wasn't
expecting that heat
[Music]
oh man
very good these
are
why did you do this
why did you do this
toss it in the sauce why just squirt it
on here like as an afterthought honey
barbecue right is this not nuts this is
nuts right that they did it like this
oh good thought
so domino's also does their wings in
boneless flavors they have obviously
those three and you can also get these
two other ones and i see we have a
crispy bacon and tomato and this one
must be the spicy jalapeno pineapple
whoa what
hell yeah all right get that b-roll fast
there it go
i know
you're you're
your audible gasps are warranted i don't
know what this
what am i supposed to do with this oh
that's what i'm looking forward to yuli
we got the food less than an hour ago
i don't think an hour
was unrealistic for food to sit i think
you guys got to put some more chemicals
in your cheese to keep it goopy or
longer oh i got some pineapple and i got
some jalapeno and i got some chicken
let's check it out
yeah
overall
everything here tastes pretty good
presentation you gotta work on that in
japan we don't have boneless wings but
we have japanese fried chicken which is
called karage it kinda looks like
american boneless wings
i love karage
and also we have chicken nuggets
both come in 4 8 and 12 pieces our
dominoes has breads and oven baked dips
let's review the breads first shall we
over here we have parmesan bread twists
and garlic bread twists i know that
because of their totally twisted shapes
we also have parmesan bread bites that
were currently unavailable
whoa
oh
these are very good
to parmesan we go uh
that is not as good but still pretty
good
i mean it's bread and cheese and oil
right u.s diamonds also has something
called stuffed cheesy bread
you can hear stuffed cheesy bread with
either spinach and veta or bacon and
jalapenos take a while to guess which
one i chose
just ripping this whole thing apart oh
god
this thing is especially greasy
for whatever reason
ah dominoes didn't stop there domino's
has something called dips
what it appears to be
is a giant dish of melted cheese and you
can get it in cheesy marinara for five
cheese
what are we doing dominos
what is this
come on guys
so this is the marinara one i'm assuming
a pizza without the bread
right this these dips are literally
zapping my will to live
this please don't ever get
it's a whole bowl of cheese yuli
why would oh look at the oil in this too
everyone in here just gagged
can i even dip it
oh whoa
i don't know what of the five jesus is
in here like which five
[Music]
so here are japanese exclusive cider
menu items let's start with this one
we've got
oven baked potato veggies
this one is plain
consomme
chili garlic
and this one is butter
and next we have
cheese sticks
shrimp popcorn
it comes with this tartar sauce here we
have choregi salad we've got korean
style
uh seaweed flakes and three dores thing
so turkey is like korean style like
sesame oil dressing
and
fresh salad in the package
so here we have
corn potage
clam chowder minestrone black chili
you've seen these before it is the
domino's marbled cookie brownies
liquid sugar oh yeah
you can also get these cinnamon bread
twists lastly
another dip i swear to god
if there's cheese in this i'm walking
out of here and i'm never coming back
baked apple dips and i'm assuming you
dip these into this
i'm not gonna so here are other desserts
we have mini pancakes
heart-shaped fonda chocolate
and here we have
egg custard tart
i've never tried this one before
itadakimasu
this is so good
so flaky
so this one is apple pie
and next we have
custard high
lastly
of the sodas you can get in the u.s
can't get in japan get yourself fanta
orange and sprite
we have
coke
zero it's supposed to be zero but they
gave us just normal coke next we have
ginger ale
canada dry canada is an amazing country
a
cool orange juice
and here is soul gambija it's like
japanese blended tea
and last one we've got
georgia japan craft cafe latte
georgia japan
sounds like george japan
i'd like to be sponsored by you let me
try this
it's got a lot of milk
and sugar in it
i gotta be honest
it's not my taste
[Laughter]
take two
i really love this
please give me a sponsorship
[Music]
a japan learned how to toast pizza it's
130 calories per slice or
1560 calories for the full pizza
in the u.s a large hand tossed pizza
slice is 280 calories which makes the
entire pizza 2
and forty calories a large big pepperoni
hannah toast slice is 335 calories per
slice or four thousand twenty calories
for the entire pizza our large pepperoni
is 370 calories per slice which makes
the entire pie 2
960 calories japan's most calorific
pizza is the ultra cheese new yorker
size one slice is
478 calories that's 3
3827 for the full pizza
our us dominus pizza with the most
calories is the cali chicken bacon ranch
this is an xl of said pizza one slice
560 calories and that makes the full pie
3
360 calories
our allergy plan pizza has 1 620
calories total our large cheese is 2 240
calories that's a 38.2
increase our large big pepperoni is
2680 calories over 34 of your daily
recommended calorie intake 333
of your daily sodium
too many tasty calories ours is 2960
calories 48
over your daily recommended amounts but
somehow ours has less sodium only
299
of your daily sodium
in october of last year a study found
detectable amounts of phthalates a
plastic softener and common menu items
from large fast food chains including
dominoes
the study analyzed 64 food samples from
several popular fast food chains and
found
phthalites
dnbp and dehp in a majority of the items
usa today reported that food containing
meat such as chicken burritos and
cheeseburgers had higher levels of the
chemical study while cheese pizza had
the lowest levels okay so that's good
news for dominoes i guess the study goes
on to say that food handling gloves
contain replacement plasticizers which
may be the source of food contamination
sounds to me like an easy fix just
prepare the food without gloves
japan has a ban on dehp in food handling
globes
gooder news if you're a fan of food wars
and saw the us vs uk domino's episode we
highlighted bha and bht in the u.s
pepperoni
well on the stewardship page on domino's
website they have stated
we have eliminated a long list of
ingredients from all of our core
products including bha and bht and phos
as well as trans fats from core pizza
products which is fantastic news i
clearly was going to eat it anyway but
thank you regardless
our cricket is back
nothing can stop the mating call of the
north america or the
the west coast cricket okay here we go